in states called fethullah gulen and
allegations that the movement within the
military were loyal to Fethullah Gulen
who is a former ally of President
Erdogan but had been caught up in
allegations of a corruption scandal
which had indicted president Erdogan in
any kind of coup situation it's not a
black and white situation and there will
be people on the ground who will want to
a continued fighting will be won't have
got word even potentially that president
Erdogan has landed back in Istanbul so
people who don't know that it's time to
give up the fight or either don't want
to give up the fight but I think that
the impression that's emerging is that
this we're just going to break in at the
moment these are live pictures on the
right hand side of your screen from
Istanbul at quarter to 7:00 in the
morning some astonishing pictures not
these ones if we can go to the ones that
we saw a few moments ago these appear to
be soldiers involved in this attempted
military coup on the Bosphorus Bridge in
Istanbul it looks as though with their
hands raised that they are surrendering
to I presume government forces and the
government police it's not live pictures
but this was only just a few minutes ago
on the Bosphorus Bridge in Istanbul